you are surrounded by people that
believe in the mission that love you
are there friends or colleagues in your
inner circle you trust that call you out
on your whenever your thinking
may be misguided as it is for leaders at
times i think we have a famously open
company culture
um
where we sort of encourage that kind of
dissent internally which is you know why
there's so much material internally that
can leak out with people sort of
disagreeing is because that's sort of
the culture
um you know our management team i think
it's a lot of people you know there's
some newer folks who come in there are
some folks who who have kind of been
there for a while but there's a very
high level of trust and
i would say it is a relatively
confrontational group of people and my
my friends and family i think um will
push me on this but look
it's not just but but i think
you need some diversity right it can't
just be um
you know people who are your friends and
family it's also you know i mean there
are
there are journalists or analysts or um
you know pure uh
executives at other companies or um you
know
other people who who sort of are
insightful about thinking about the
world you know certain politicians um or
people kind of in that sphere who i just
think have like very insightful
perspectives who
um
even if they would
they come at the world from a different
perspective which is sort of what makes
the perspective so valuable but
you know i think fundamentally you're
trying to get to the same place in terms
of
you know helping people connect more
helping um the whole world function
better not just you know one place or
another um
and
i don't know i mean those are the people
whose opinions
really matter to me and i just it's you
know that's how i learn on a day-to-day
basis people are constantly sending me
comments on stuff or links to things
they found interesting and um and i
don't know it's it's kind of constantly
evolving this model of the world and
kind of what we should be aspiring to be
you